it's been said before that there is a
tool for every job and that there is no
problem out there too big that cannot be
fixed without the proper application of
the proper tool but sometimes problems
are too complex for just one tool
sometimes like when you're Batman
fighting a never-ending war against
crime and villainy you need an entire
arsenal and where else would you keep it
but in your trusty utility belt I'm Cave
Joel join me today as I take a closer
look at Batman's utility belt the
utility belt is easily one of the oldest
and most recognizable pieces of Batman
equipment with the hero since day one
when he first premiered in the pages of
Detective Comics number 27 all the way
back in September 1939 the belt is used
for a lot more than just keeping up the
Dark Knight's pants it also houses all
of that man's different crime-fighting
devices while no one is exactly 100%
certain of its contents most of the time
as Batman tends to change his loadout to
better fit his current situation the
belt is usually stocked with batarangs
and holds Batman's gas powered grappling
gun while perhaps unremarkable looking
at first glance the belt has more in
common with a D&D bag of holding capable
of carrying whatever the writers feel
Batman should need and much much more
the belt has undergone a number of style
changes over the years from just a
simple yellow line around Batman's waist
to being a much more bulky commando
style set of pouches like in the pages
of Batman year one to being something
more in line with a soldier's tactical
wear like today as a fighter Batman's
utility belt comes complete with all
manner of weapons including bat darts
thermite grenades smoke bombs for
confusing enemies or for making a quick
escape and sometimes even a lone marvel
for well you know I'm not exactly sure
what that's for but when you're Batman
you can always find a use for a single
marble now in his role as a detective
and keeping the peace Batman also uses
his utility belt to help carry around
all his CSI tech including but not
limited to things like evidence bags
fingerprint dusting kits and bat tracers
sometimes even bat-cuffs and those are
just the obvious tools of the
crime-fighting trade what about some of
the more outlandish things Batman has
ever kept in his belt over the years how
about some Kryptonite for battling rogue
Kryptonian silver nitrate anti-fire foam
and everyone's favorite Adam West
edition bat shark repellent yes Batman
is indeed always prepared even for
sharks now over the course of his 75
years Batman's foes have always been
very drawn to his utility belt as a
symbol of Batman strength to deter
thieves BAM in his place all manner of
security measures including special
locks that only he can open as well as
powerful stun gases writers also use
this as a chance to ratchet up tension
oh no Batman lost his utility belt how
is he possibly going to get out of this
one the utility belt has become such an
important piece of Batman's crusade on
crime and villainy that all of his
sidekicks and affiliated Bat family
characters have their own variation on
the belt I swear it's like a membership
card or something you become a Robin you
get a bell and that everyone is a little
primer on probably the most super
accessory out there I hope you all
learned a little something from the
video and until next time I'm Gabe Joel
and I will see you next time